Rusia ha confirmado hace unas pocas
horas que rompe un lateralmente el
acuerdo por el grano y cereal ucraneal
que se llegó en Estambul en el pasado
mes de julio a través del cual Ucrania
podía continuar con sus exportaciones de
grano y cereal que fueron interrumpidas
a través del bloqueo ruso impuesto por
Rusia cuando en febrero invadió al país
ucraniano Rusia explicado que rompe este
acuerdo por el ataque de esta misma
mañana con drones en contra de la flota
naval rusa dentro del mar Negro a
Naciones Unidas ha asegurado después del
anuncio de Rusia de la rotura de este
acuerdo que pedía todas las partes a
intentar a limitar las acciones que
podría que puedan poner en peligro este
acuerdo que sirvió en julio para bajar
los precios internacionales de un grano
y un cereal que estaban disparados como
también lo estaba el precio del gas en
todo el mundo el acuerdo tenía que
renovarse el 19 de noviembre de este
mismo año dentro de un par de semanas y
todas las partes tenían que estar de
acuerdo en esta renovación para que
fuese efectiva y pudiese Durante los
próximos 120 días sin embargo Moscú
había estado dando señales sobre todo en
la última semana en la que parecía no
estar muy dispuesta a renovar un acuerdo
que aseguramos Cuba beneficiado sobre
todo a Ucrania pero muy poco menos de lo
que esperaba a la Moscú que ha visto
como las sanciones europeas siguen
manteniendo el trigo y las fertilizantes
rusos mantenidos en Rusia según este
acuerdo Ucrania pudo empezar las
exportaciones de las cerca de 22
millones de toneladas de grano y
cereales que estaban bloqueados en
Ucrania desde julio Hasta ahora se
calcula que en torno a unas 7 u 8
millones de toneladas han sido
exportados a través de los puertos
ucranianos a través de Estambul para
llegar a muchos puertos europeos e
internacionales a partir de ahora sin
embargo con la rotura rusa si esta se
confirman las próximas horas en las
exportaciones de trigo crane No tendrán
que parar por completo